throughout history political activists
have endured all manner of suffering in
order to advance their causes Gandhi
marched 240 miles to protest the British
salt Monopoly Nelson Mandela spent 27
years in prison opposing the South
African regime and yesterday Democrat
Congressman Greg kasar stopped eating
for eight hours to protest for more
breaks in the workday in Texas when
Congressman casear first demanded more
time offer employees I didn't know if he
was serious
but when the congressman for went his
mid-afternoon snack to bring attention
to the issue I knew he meant business
now of course there was a time when
Americans weren't such fatties that they
could go a few hours without stuffing
their faces and not hold a press
conference about it there was even a
time when people fasted regularly as a
matter of religious or even just
physical discipline but those days are
gone and in the decadent year of Our
Lord 2023 a brief Interruption of
gluttony constitutes an act of political
heroism I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the Michael Knowles show
Congressman case are this brief
Interruption of stuffing himself
actually was not the craziest thing on
Capitol Hill yesterday
there's a lot going on you know I'm
still in Hungary and we'll get to a
fabulous statement that prime minister
Victor Orban just made here I'll be
speaking later on today at the MCC Fest
in egerstrom in Hungary but going back
to Capitol Hill for a second the
craziest thing that took place at
Capitol Hill yesterday was the UFO
hearing and
I went in and I wanted to keep an open
mind and you know we've had some debates
about aliens at the daily wire I
cannot overstate just how stupid these
hearings are I predicted they would be
stupid I tried to keep it they're G it's
so dumb and so
obviously fake
but let's hear them out uh first clip
from Congressman Tim burchett asking
and this is a very serious question has
anyone been injured or harmed retrieving
or even covering up the supposed alien
spacecraft
do you have any personal knowledge of
people have been harmed or injured in
efforts to cover up or conceal these
extraterrestrial technology yes
personally
have you heard have anyone been murdered
that you would think that you know of or
have heard of I guess I have to be
careful asking that question I directed
people with that knowledge to the
appropriate authorities maybe in a um if
we could get it get in a
confidential area skiff we could talk
about that but unfortunately
um we were denied access to the skiff
and that's very unfortunate in this in
this scenario
skiff is a secure setting where you can
talk about sensitive information the
implication here
is that
either aliens have murdered Americans
American servicemen and other government
workers
or that the government has murdered
Americans for knowing too much about
aliens that the implication here is
every sci-fi horror alien movie come to
life that's the implication and I use
that word carefully it's an implication
because
we don't have any names we don't have
any dates we don't have any evidence we
just have this guy's testimony I am not
questioning the guy's Integrity I'm not
saying he's lying I just can't help but
notice we talked about this on the show
yesterday
every single time we've we've got the
Smoking Gun we've got proof of an alien
and UFOs and flying saucers
we don't get it we don't get the details
we just get insinuations and
implications and trust me I know you got
to trust me if only we could get into
the skiff if only I could tell you what
happened if only I could give you names
if only I could give you details so this
is amazing Brighton circus's TV that the
American public is gobbling up I'm
talking about it right now on the show
so I guess it worked but is there any
actual substance to what they're saying
Anna Paulina Luna Republican Congressman
asks if
the man testifying has ever feared for
his life following up on this question
of have people been murdered in these
cover-ups have people been injured
here's his answer
in the last couple of years have you had
incidences that have caused you to be in
fear for your life for addressing these
issues
yes personally
yeah I just want everyone to note that
he's coming forward in fear of his life
to put in perspective if they were
really not scared about this information
coming out why would someone be
intimidated like that
okay maybe he is in fear of his life
look maybe it's real all right let's
just say maybe ET is real and we've got
all these aliens and spacecraft and
secret bunkers in area 51. okay
but again
where is the evidence this exchange
which is captivating and it's gone viral
and people are talking about it he this
man fears for his life what kind of
evidence is that the evidence being
presented here is a guy's feelings
I don't mean to mock his feelings but
when we're talking about Congressional
testimony when we're talking about the
little green men I would rather hear
some facts and details and evidence
because these kinds of insinuations can
be made about anything well yes I did
feel I felt very threatened this is what
the libs say on college campuses they
say I felt unsafe when you called me by
a pronoun that I don't like and
therefore I felt like it was really
dangerous and threatening feel feel you
can never disprove a feeling so I'm
really not mocking the guy I'm I I don't
mean to be harsh on him but
give me something if we're going to hold
this big circus hearing give me anything
real
Nancy mace got the closest I think to An
Answer another Republic liberal
Republican Congress lady Nancy mace asks
all right you're afraid for your life
you're saying people have been
threatened and harmed and injured and
all about this well do we have the goods
do we have spacecraft do we have alien
bodies and this answer
to me is the most telling of the entire
testimony though in a way that's
different from how most people are
interpreting it
if you believe we have crashed craft uh
stated earlier do we have the bodies of
the pilots who piloted this craft
as I've stated publicly already in my
news Nation interview biologics came
with some of these recoveries yeah
um
were they I guess human or non-human
biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program and was this
documentary references video photos
eyewitness like how would that be
determined
the specific documentation I would have
to talk to you to skip about
now if only we got that skiff that would
have been nice the word that perked my
ears up here
biologics
the hell is biologics that's a weird
word that's a weird clinical jargony
word
that nobody really knows the meaning of
but did he did he mean bodies well he
would have just said bodies did he mean
tissue organs splattered alien guts no
biologics which is a term that when it
is used and it's used very rarely is
often used with regard to Medicine
it's not what does that mean man it was
non-human biologics okay
what could that could be anything you
could recover a craft that had some
other organism in it had a single cell
organism in it they said well that's
biologics we got it had some other kind
of tissue I don't know some guy had a
cat hair on him what what is it when are
we going to get specific now what the
man testifying here says is well I would
just need to be in a skiff to get
specific about that okay
can the congress not do it
can the congress not demand
the opportunity to to meet with this guy
off the Record in a skiff
Maybe not maybe maybe it is a super
duper deep secret cover-up and we've
been storing alien bodies and
refrigerators for a long time
but
what seems more likely to you
that
ET is real and in a bunker somewhere
Underground
or that the government is distracting
you
or that gullible people are following
fantasies or that
what that it at the moment that we've
got really pressing National matters
the U.S Congress and the bureaucracy are
putting on a bread and circuses show
that is succeeding because we're all
talking about it what do you seems more
the thing seems more likely if it were
the case
that it were the former if it were the
case that we really have all these alien
bodies
why have we never ever ever gotten even
one hard detail verifiable piece of
evidence about any of it in all the
decades that people have been talking
about it including the last few years
where it's really come up
what seems more likely to you I I think
I've got my answer Mr Walsh has his
answer
which slider you on pick a side man you
stand in the middle of the road you're
going to get hit by a UFO you got to
talk to your friends about these things
when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles you know a
company is looking out for you when they
actually upgrade your service and don't
charge you for it this is great news for
new and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but haven't made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot this is why I
love Pure Talk veteran owned they only
hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great us of a
that alone is worth switching most
families are saving almost a thousand
dollars a year while enjoying the most
Dependable 5G Network in America
remember
you vote with how you spend your money
so stop supporting wireless companies
that don't support you go to
puretalk.com Knowles you'll save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they value you go to
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
for Americans buy Americans that is
puretalk.com
slash noise
speaking of bizarre claims coming from
our government Joe Biden made a claim
just yesterday about
one of his great successes
that I don't really remember happening
I said I'd cure cancer it looked at me
like why cancer because no one thinks we
can
that's why and we can
I mean and the cancer as we know it
do you remember Joe Biden curing cancer
I remember at the end of the Obama
Administration
Barack Obama said Joe we're gonna take a
moonshot and put you in charge of curing
cancer
to which every single person in America
said oh well so much for that so much
for getting a cure for cancer we got Joe
in charge that's a guarantee it's never
going to get done and Joe Biden
reiterated his desire to cure cancer
again and hasn't done it obviously
cancer still exists cancer is still very
dangerous and Biden's done essentially
nothing on it and now he's declaring
victory
this is Joe Biden's George Bush standing
on the aircraft carrier with the mission
accomplished sign except he's not going
to get any Flack for it no one's really
going to call him out some of us in the
conservative media well it won't matter
it won't matter that Joe Biden is
brazenly lying and pretending to have
achieved an implausible achievement
which we all know he did not achieve
and some people are shocked
some people I am not shocked do you know
why
because these guys say that men are
women with a straight face these guys
tell you to your face that a man is
really a woman
and they've gotten a lot of us to go
along with it
this is the point I know it's an
overused literary reference this is the
point of the final chapters of 1984. the
point is
not that the evil regime is going to lie
it's not that the evil regime is going
to deceive you it's not even that the
evil regime is going to torture you
until you utter the LIE knowing that
it's a lie
it's that the evil regime is going to
confuse you so much it's going to mess
with your head and your perception of
reality so much that you're you're not
even going to be able to discern the
difference between truth and lies you'll
believe the lie and then when they
change their story you're going to
believe the the contradictory changed
story and you are going to be so
disoriented that you're not even going
to notice it and that's what's Happening
Here Joe Biden says yeah I cured cancer
making tiny little ripples in the media
it's going to be on my show maybe a
handful of other conservative shows
they're going to move on it's not going
to matter and some people some people
are going to believe it they're going to
be Libs 10 20 years from now remember
when Joe Biden cured cancer oh yeah now
I remember that
speaking of
[Music]
so what do the youngsters think about
all of this what are the youths that is
going to be speaking to what do they
think about it well there's some good
news on that front actually
I'll start with the bad news I'll give
you the good news the bad news is about
my generation the Millennials the poor
Millennials at 44 of Millennials think
that
misgendering you know referring to
someone by the correct pronouns when you
call a man he and you call a woman she
if they think that they're the opposite
sex 44 of Millennials think that should
be a criminal offense that you could go
to jail for calling a man he
35 of Millennials disagree they don't
think it should be a criminal offense
and 26 percent either don't know or
don't really have an opinion on the
subject so the vast majority 65 either
think it should be criminal or don't
really care if it's Criminal the good
news is Zoomers are way more
conservative way more in line with
reality and way more based so uh among
gen Z
33 a third think that misgendering quote
unquote should be a criminal offense
that's still a huge number
but it's way lower 25 lower than the
Millennials and 48 disagree so much
higher percentage actively think no we
shouldn't criminalize people for calling
dudes he and him the remainder say uh
neither or don't know other polls that
have come out show that the Zoomers also
are way less down on the agenda way less
down with the agenda I guess they're
more down on the agenda they're anti
at a much higher rate than the
Millennials are this is good stuff makes
me think that the kids are all right why
is that happening
I think it's because the Millennials
came of political age in the age of
Obama in the age of idealism and fantasy
and they came out of the last gasps of a
semi-normal society into hope and change
and happy Obama and Madness the Zoomers
came of political age when that balloon
of optimism popped they came of
political age at a time when the last
vestiges of normality were gone they
came at a time of rising populism they
came at a time when
conservatives stopped losing politely
and you had McCain and and Romney as
saying well you know Barack Obama he's a
really good man I just we happen to
disagree and it's my job to lose to him
that was over by the time Trump came
around and he said Mexican immigrants
are rapists and murderers Barack Obama
probably wasn't born in this country
Hillary Clinton should go to prison like
I'm not saying everything he said was
nice or even true or anything like that
I'm just saying all those niceties went
away and Trump went is not only a cause
of this reaction but he was an
expression of it as well and the bright
side of that the bright side of that
crassness and bluntness is that
this younger generation that came of age
at that time
they're they're not going to go along
with the BS
the Millennials are all about the BS the
Zoomers not going to go along with it
they're they're sick of it they were not
raised in an age when that was going to
be really hopeful and exciting uh
boys and boys and girls are girls now
when you want to hire people you should
not obviously not hire Millennials and
only hire Zoomers because they
understand the world a lot better you
should also check out super recruiter
right now go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles
if you're hiring you're probably dealing
with economic uncertainty now more than
ever it's important to hire the right
people faster and more efficiently to
keep overall costs down thankfully
ZipRecruiter is a hiring partner focused
on you and your needs from pricing to
technology everything that zip recruiter
does is for you and what works best for
you right now you can try them for free
at ziprecruiter.com Knowles zip
recruiters smart technology identifies
and matches for your job and lets you
invite candidates you really want to
apply to your job before other
businesses can snag them I love their
pricing it's super straightforward you
know what you pay before posting your
job so you can stick to your budget with
no surprises hire the best with the help
of a partner who's all about you with
zip recruiter four out of five employers
who post on the recruiter get a quality
candidate Within first day go to this
exclusive web address right now
ziprecruiter.com
Knowles try it for free that is
k-n-o-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest
way
to hire
folks the greatest interview show
on the internet yes or no is back with
an all new episode with movie star Jim
Caviezel and American hero Tim Ballard
to discuss the sound of Freedom movie
phenomenon
check out this teaser
coincidence that many Elites in
Hollywood and big Tech are
harsh as critics for the sound of
Freedom movie does Michael think it's a
coincidence
I was thinking about it for a second
don't give me the answer
it's cheating it's cheating
[Music]
what it is what it is we are
go get the yes or no game right now not
just the video but the actual game it's
in stock
go to dailywater.com shop get your game
today the games go fast yes or no it's
hands down the best way to delve into
the most thought-provoking topics of our
time with family with friends go to
daily wire.com shop and order yes or no
today
speaking of the youths is any of my show
going to be allowed on YouTube today is
that this is a big
this is a big go to Twitter go to the
RSS feed go to Apple podcast go to daily
wire plus day because I think my YouTube
version of my show is going to be about
three minutes today but we got to talk
about this there is a taxpayer funded
[Music]
you know another authoritarian leader
happens to be the best leader in Europe
Victor Orban I'm in Hungary right now so
I'm paying a little closer attention to
Hungarian politics or Bond just came out
in a great line
he said we're not a liberal democracy
we're in a liberal democracy actually
we're a Christian democracy and just a
couple days ago said
by having rejected Christianity we have
in actual fact become hedonistic pagans
that is true he's describing Europe I
think this could apply to the West
broadly
it's not that by rejecting Christianity
we've just become enlightened and
secular and we don't do those religious
rituals anymore we just do different
ones and we just got out of a month
where we were doing religious rituals
all the time with the with the special
body paint the rainbows and the flags
and the the big parades the processions
we used to have processions to the
Blessed Mother we used to have
processions that involved great saints
that involved our Lord now we have
processions that involve deviant men
wearing leather smacking each other in
front of children on floats
their processions and what it what kind
of A procession is that it's not just
liberalism it's not just secularism it's
not just having a little fun it's
hedonistic paganism prime minister Orban
just hit the nail on the head we will be
talking about a lot of these things
tomorrow when I'm at the MCC Fest
speaking in egerstrom I think I'm
mispronouncing that but I'm very excited
to do that and that will be conclude my
trip and then we'll we'll come back and
and be back in the studio next week
gotta restore some standards folks
there's a there's a story I don't know
since since two-thirds of the show it's
not on YouTube anyway might as well get
into it today a little tease at the very
least Malaysia's government just stepped
into hot water as Malaysia it's not evil
western or Bond it's Malaysia which I
think the libs still consider good
because it's non-western so Malaysia
halted a concert by a band called the
1975. what is that I don't know it says
here it's a British pop rock band and
the Malaysian government halted this
concert because two dudes on stage two
members of the band started kissing each
other and Malaysia came in and said nah
you're not going to do that here oh no
how terrible how awful the Liberals up
in arms a reminder
that the Liberals for all their talk
about multiculturalism have absolutely
no respect for anyone else's culture the
Biden Administration during pride month
I heard this from a liberal journalist
in Hungary she was in favor of this I
was quite opposed to it the Biden
Administration sent
a big gay pride flag even though Hungary
is anti-public LGBT stuff said a big
pride flag had a big Pride Celebration
in the embassy they forget about Hungary
they did it at the Vatican
they it's so disrespectful
we say oh we need multiculturalism we
need to bring everybody in our culture
is so evil we we want to learn from all
the cultures of the world and then in
the very next breath these liberals
impose their radical hedonistic Pagan
ideology
unto others
you know when Jordan Peterson made the
decision to join daily wire plus it was
a major win for those who Champion
intellectual debate with one year of
unparalleled output his contributions
have set new standards and remained
unmatched by any other platform daily
wire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan Peterson content
offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content you won't find
anywhere else Jordan has created
thought-provoking works that reshape
your perspective on life which include
vision and Destiny marriage and Dragons
monsters and men it's a lot of stuff
Additionally you can immerse yourself in
discussions that nurture your spiritual
side like logos and literacy and
Jordan's groundbreaking series on the
book of Exodus I have not even mentioned
his Beyond order lecture series or have
extensive his extensive Archive of
lectures and podcasts this is the
compendium of all things Jordan plus
there is even more new exclusive content
on the Horizon by becoming a daily wire
plus member you will embark on an
unforgettable experience that will fuel
your thirst for knowledge and Inspire
personal growth like never before and
that will make you clean your room so go
to dailywire.com subscribe become a
member today finally finally we've
arrived at my favorite time of the week
when I get to hear from you in the
mailbag this mailbag is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter code Knowles kwles to get
fifty percent five zero percent off your
first month
let's take it away hi Michael I'm a
fellow Catholic and new tier show and
heard you mention how you and your wife
came back together after some time apart
I was wondering how realistic that would
be in my situation I met the most
amazing man and we were in a great
relationship until he made a big life
change which made him very stressed and
overwhelmed he told me he couldn't be in
a relationship but that he wanted to see
me again in the future
it's been almost a year we don't talk
but we're on good terms and I still hold
on to the hope that we can get back
together I'm 37 he's 47 we had a solid
connection and we're honest with each
other I keep hoping that he will come
back but I don't know what else I can do
at this point any advice thank you
yes I'm sorry to hear about your
situation I would dump that zero and get
yourself a hero that's what I would do
he sounds like a schmuck
I know you like him still and I don't
know why he instigated this breakup and
he needed time to find himself or
whatever nonsense but he sounds like a
big putz and you should dump him sorry
to say I know I'm sure you like him and
maybe you guys spent a lot of time
together but
there there
are ways to get back together with
someone that you've broken up with
obviously I'm living proof of that but
the the thing that got me about what you
said is you don't talk
and I don't think there's really a way
to get back together or it's much less
likely that you will get back together
if you're not still talking so you're on
good terms it was a perfectly fine
breakup but you're not still talking
you're not in each other's lives and
you're holding out this hope for this
guy and what is he saying he had a big
life change I don't know what the life
change is it really could be anything it
could be maybe what did he get a new job
did he did a family member die did he
have to move somewhere whatever it is if
a man
especially men of his age cannot handle
whatever that change is there going to
be a lot of changes in life life comes
at you fast and also maintain a loving
relationship that one hopes moves
towards marriage then he's just not the
right guy he might be the sweetest guy
in the world he just doesn't have his
act together okay you should have a guy
who does have his act together so
so I'm sorry to give harsh advice here
because maybe there's a one percent
chance that you guys could get back
together I wouldn't I wouldn't hang my
hopes on that dump him you can do better
my dear
next question hey Michael this is Marty
one of your senior citizen fans thank
you for great shows and the way you
present things and entertain us
my question to you is why do we let the
left control the language
why do we let them control it in the way
that they include the LGB whenever they
talk about the issue
aren't they really manipulating us
into having to accept all rather than
being able to point out the fact that
this agenda
and non-binary stuff is a lie and we do
not go along with it
uh your points on that would be welcomed
and how can we help the Republicans run
for office if we do separate it like
this
really and God bless thank you so much
that's a really great question
so
why do we allow them to do it we allow
them to do it because they control the
institutions
wrote a little book called speechless
do I have we don't have a belt here in
Hungary it was it would be too expensive
to check that but wrote a book called
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds about how the libs uh control the
language because language makes up the
stuff of our Consciousness so they can
win debates before the debates are even
had like on the redefinition of marriage
when when the left changed the the topic
from What is marriage to who has the
right to get married will we have
marriage equality they basically won the
debate before there ever was a debate
because if the debate becomes a question
of who has a right then we all are
supposed to have rights the question was
always What is marriage does sexual
difference have something to do with
marriage which obviously does uh they
were able to do that because they
control the media they control the
education system they control the
bureaucracy they control all of the
institutions that push that language on
us and it just seeps in you will find
yourself using their language a lot the
other reason here though for the LGB
getting lumped in with the T I know
there's a big movement of people who say
hey especially among gay and lesbian
identifying people who say hey we don't
want anything to do with that
get that out of here we don't want the
tea the tea is crazy we're actually the
T undermines the LGB part because the
LGB part says we're born this way and uh
what is a what is a g is a guy who
is Andrew rotate I guess calls himself
top G what is the what is gay though it
means you're a man who is attracted to
other men well if men can be women and
women can be men and there's no such
real category as men well then gay no
longer makes any sense I get all of that
the reason they're naturally lumped
together though is because
all of it requires a rejection of a
traditional sexual ethic a religious
sexual ethic and once you reject that
once you change the sexual ethic from
what it has always been what is your
body for what is the purpose of our
sexuality are there are there bad things
that we can do with our sexual organs
once you lose that and you reframe the
moral question to if it feels good do it
then you you've accepted the premise
when you accept the idea that men and
women are basically interchangeable such
that the union of two men is basically
the same as the union of a man and a
woman well then you've accepted the
premise that will lead
which is that men and women are so
similar that one can become the other
one so that's why how do we encourage
Republicans well we can tell them to be
on guard about language we can try to
gain power in the institutions to wield
it in a way that that imposes our
language which is more in line with
reality onto the culture but I don't
think we're going to do it by splitting
errors over the LGB and the T I like it
or not that they're lumped together
next question
hey Michael I came for Ben and stayed
for you and backstage episodes all right
I'm a practicing Catholic who like many
other Catholic struggles to reconcile
Catholic teachings with this Fallen
World
I find that when you know someone
personally then your beliefs while so
strong show real world consequence to
someone you are friends with
my example would be Dave Rubin who I'm
also a big fan of while I agree with and
understand why gay marriage is wrong
how do you actively Advocate against gay
marriage when Dave Rubin is in a gay
marriage himself with children
if you are his friend and became a
senator for example how can you maintain
a great relationship with him if he's
aware that if you theoretically would
have the Congressional vote that you
would choose to vote to dissolve his
marriage
how could he want a friendship with you
if you have that goal
thanks for the show I listened daily and
it creates great conversation and debate
in my family and especially with my kids
have a great day thank you very much
that's a really good question and I'll
broaden it out a little bit I've gotten
all sorts of questions about specific
friends of mine and I'll try to broaden
it out because I think you know my
friend as you point out my friends are
my friends and so if I'm gonna have a
conversation that involves some personal
issue of theirs I'll probably have it
privately but
it's a great observation because I'm
from New York I went to Yale and I lived
in Los Angeles and worked in Show
Business
a disproportionate number of my friends
are of the homosexual persuasion okay I
went both places on the coast a little
light in the loafers and Yale is the
gayest University ever in all of history
so yeah I've got a lot of friends who
are inclined that way and how do I
remain friends with them well I think
it's because I'm not wishy-washy about
what I think
I I think if
if I had an opinion and I said well
marriage just intrinsically involves
sexual difference and it that's just
what marriage is but then I went up to a
gay identifying any kind of identifying
friend of mine and uh so well actually
though but then I don't that didn't
exactly mean that and that and then it
would seem that I am not holding a view
that's grounded in reason that I'm
holding a view that's grounded in
nothing more but bigotry and Prejudice
and and then they they might have a real
cause to be upset with me but I'm not
afraid to say it because it's just my
view and my friends Respect My Views
just as I respect that they have in good
faith come to their own views and and so
uh you know the notion that uh if I were
in public office
and this issue were politically viable
that I would vote
to define marriage is what marriage
really is I I don't think that would
upset anybody I've got friends who are
in uh same so-called same-sex marriages
and I like their partners and some of
them are dear dear friends of mine and
I'm not saying I'm going to throw these
people in the gulag you know not
suggesting anything that I think would
be harmful to them of course not
the law itself is an ordinance of reason
for the common good by him who has care
of the community and promulgated so
any law that I would support I would
support on the basis that I believe
sincerely and I think with good reason
that it is for the common good not just
for the greater good and it's going to
hurt some people not in a utilitarian
sense but in the classical sense of the
common good whereby it is the the good
of all of us and of the polity and of
our individual good as whether there's
no real distinction uh exactly there so
so that's what I would say I mean I'm
sure I've got friends who disagree with
me for all sorts of things and I
disagree with them but if you know if
you love somebody if you're if you're
Pals with somebody then you know that
you're not coming from a place of of uh
cruelty or not willing to good of the
other person you know if you if you're
friends with somebody then you have love
for that person and love as we've said
many times on the show
certainly a key Catholic understanding
of Love is that it's willing the good of
the other person for their own sake next
question good morning Michael first off
I've been listening to your show for
quite some time and I really appreciate
that you not only addressed the major
issues facing our society
but also address the spiritual warfare
behind all of it it's my question I'm
curious about your take on different
Christian denominations
my family and I attend a church that
would fall into the non-denominational
category
we believe in the Bible and that
repentance and a relationship with Jesus
is their only way to Salvation and
eternal life
I know that you belong to the Catholic
church and that you often refer to
Catholic traditions on your show
do you believe that Catholicism is the
only way to Salvation or is it more of a
difference of style and tradition if so
do you believe that all sects of
Christianity lead to Salvation are there
ones that get it completely wrong
again thank you for your continued work
to Bringing truth to the world
really good question
I'm Catholic and so I believe that the
Catholic Church possesses the fullness
of truth I think it's the real church
that Christ instituted and one of the
evidences of this I take it on faith but
one of the evidences of this according
to the great writer Hillary bellock is
that uh if the church were not divinely
instituted uh no other navish no other
uh institution conducted with such Navy
imbecility would have lasted a fortnight
so the problems and the scandals and the
corruption in a way are a kind of an
Evidence is nothing but divine grace
could possibly have allowed an
institution so mismanaged to uh to
continue
um you say you were non-denominational
and I have many friends who call
themselves that
so many so that I would have to suggest
that the n and the D are capitalized you
know the non-denominational denomination
because it is a denomination because
people refer to it by that name I've got
family who were Baptists you know I've
got a lot of Protestants down the family
tree
um
so are all people who say that they're
Christian
saved are they Christian
uh
well the Bible seems clear enough on
this which is Christ says someday there
will be people who call me Lord Lord who
I will say I will to whom I will say I
do not know you uh so
I'm not saying that you know you and
your fellow ecclesial Community you know
you're all going to rotten hell I'm not
saying anything like that and I'm not
saying that you don't have a sincere
faith in Christ and I'm not saying that
that uh you know Christ has not bestowed
his grace upon you or anything like that
but at the very least we would have to
say that if you came out and you said
God forbid you know I believe in Jesus
well what does that mean to you well it
means you know that I believe in
and I believe in abortion I think
abortion is a really important thing
it's a Sacrament and I believe in
chopping off people's body parts and I
believe in Acts murdering people twice a
month that's my understanding of
Christianity would you say that's crazy
that's not Christianity what on Earth
are you talking about that's so but but
no I'm calling myself a Christian well
no and there are certain Christians
so-called Christian denominations which
deny important aspects of the faith
would you call them Christian well no
it'd be hard to do that
the question that I would ask myself if
I were
shopping around for different
denominations and sex and things like
that is okay I love Christ I love the
Lord I love God I want to do his will
is there a way that he wants me to
worship Him is there a way that he wants
me to have a relationship with him is
there specificity is there detail to it
does he give clues of this in the Bible
of ways that he wants us to pray what
things that he wants us to believe
Creeds that he wants us to hold does he
give us
clues in the early Christian tradition
in the early Church in the later church
is there some continuity there the first
part very important part is do you love
the Lord do you accept Christ as the
Lord your God will you be baptized and
then even as you as you're baptized okay
is there something else is it not so
much how I want to worship God but how
God wants me to worship him for my own
good
uh you see that certainly in the Old
Testament very very rigid descriptions
by God of how he wants his chosen people
to worship him and I think that remains
true today and so this process of
discernment of of what the truth of the
matter is it's not you know being
nitpicky and finicky and exclusive or
anything like that it's just asking okay
I'm with you Lord I love you
what do you want from me okay I've got
so many more things to get to but Mr
Davies won't let me do it I've got
really good mailbag questions we're
gonna have to save them
for next week or maybe you know what
maybe I'll do them in the membrane
segmentum on Monday because I've missed
you all I've missed you so much I'll be
back from Hungary very shortly see some
of you in Hungary my speech later on
today
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
the Michael Knowles show see you Monday
[Music]
foreign